this is neo face a high-tech solution to
an old police problem getting a positive
ID on who committed the crime
leicestershire police one of 43 local UK
forces are running a six-month trial to
see how it holds up we have CCTV footage
from a shop where somebody's been called
shoplifting for example or officer body
worn camera if we can get an image from
that that's a good enough quality the
operators here will then download that
image onto our search database will run
it and within two seconds it will give
any potential matches that are on there
a human operator is still needed to
check the matches there's the image if a
press identify is now going to search
the 92,000 images so it's brought back
the top 200 potentials the system
doesn't discriminate between age gender
ethnicity it's purely looking at the
facial features this is where I can zoom
in on the face and look for any
distinguishing features but also is
doing is giving the officer a potential
person but if the person isn't in the
database the system doesn't work which
means this trial run has an overall
success rate of just forty four percent
however for any see the developers
behind the software they see other
applications for neo face that don't
have the same limitations another
version allows employers to check and
monitor their staff movements in real
time replacing ID cards this is already
in operation in NEC offices the company
claims it improves security and for
retailers NEC says neo face could become
a key tool for improving sales it
recognizes returning customers allowing
staff to target certain products by
looking at previous spending habits and
according to one firm facial recognition
technology to turn your face into a
commodity worth around six and a half
billion dollars by 2018 but following
the recent scandals in mass surveillance
how the public reacts may change how the
technology affects our lives in the
future
you